everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we in round for the
2016 candidates tournament winner of
this tournament goes on to face Magnus
Carlsen in November for the World
Championship now we have three players
tied for first Saturday Kathy Hawken
vision on and Levon Aronian all three of
those players have one win and two ties
and in round four we have two of those
competitors facing off why it's gonna be
played today by seven again Kathy Hawken
and black is gonna be played by vision
on winner of the last Canada's
tournament so definitely some
powerhouses facing off today cardiac and
starts out with Knight f3 pawn d5 pawn
III and Knight f6 and then pawn at c4
and this can go a few different ways
could kind of play like an English
opening here with poncey for I could
eventually transpose into just the
Queen's Gambit with pawn here to d4 so a
lot of different options both sides are
kind of leaving it open pawn to e6 so
kind of going for that Queens gambit to
climb line if we do see a pawn here to
d4 instead to see pawn b3 something not
super common but but more typically in
line with the English opening up on to
b3 a bishop here - Abby - getting ready
to get this ad are 'scrimish been
involved into the game since it's kind
of blocked out by the pawn here on e3
and then just getting here Knight to c3
or later on pawn to d4 Knight to d2 is
also a possibility for white Bishop e7
Bishop b2 is we talked about castle on
the Kings side a Knight to c3 so
deciding to go ahead and attack the
center of the board pawn c5 pawn takes
on a d5 decided does not want to go
ahead and play Bishop here - e to allow
his opponent to come here take here on
c4 wants to go ahead and take this
Central Square here on d5 instead so
pawn takes on d5 Knight recaptures me
personally if you're looking for kind of
how I would play and how I recommend a
lot of players play is pawn takes on d5
both are gonna be completely fine
I do like controlling the siRNA to board
my pawns a little bit early on and also
opening up the door for my LightSquared
Bishop for black a lot of times for
white you have
dark square bishop it's very hard to get
involved into the game you twenty moves
in and you seen you haven't moved it at
all for black it's a light toward Bishop
right here and so if you play Knight
takes on d5 it's a little bit tougher to
get your light square Bishop involved
into the game now you know higher levels
of chess they're always gonna find
creative ways to get that involved but
if you kind of look at and you say you
know could I take with my pawn or my
Knights one option is to just go and
take with upon I think that's completely
fine besides go and take with his
Knights right here
Queen to a situ just completing
development a little bit Knight to c6
upon 2 H 4 and this is a pretty
interesting move I really expected
Bishop e2 Kass on the Kings side pawn
here to h3 potentially just maybe trying
to thwart some attack later on but ponta
h4 is pretty aggressive looking to start
to push on the Kings side of the board
still probably a little tricky with the
C file a semi-open right here to castle
on the Queen side but pawn to h4
definitely saying that he's looking to
attack on the King side of the board
now b6 and then a3 a3 just trying to
hold down this B 4 square a very potent
for both nights to come here would be a
nice little outpost so pawn to e3 is
kind of stopping that and then pawn to
f5 so vision on trying to strike back a
little bit in the center of the board
since he does see this pawn to h4 does
not want to be the the one just kind of
sitting back doesn't want to attack
aggressively Bishop here to b5 attacking
the knight getting ready to castle on
the Kings side if he would like to
Bishop to b7 so after the the pawn to b6
solidifying this pawn chain he can now
bring his Bishop out here defend both
the knight - and try to control this a
light square diagonal right here nice
now I'm going to take on at d5 and then
the pawn recaptures didn't want to do
this right away
this would allow his opponent to kind of
extend his lights for a bishop along
this diagonal right here but once he
played Bishop to b7 he recognized that
he could go ahead and exchange here if
he wanted to and after pawn to d5 the
lights were busy would have to come back
to ca to kind of control
this so you know start to get doing a
good job of kind of waiting to see what
his opponent does in then exchange those
nights here he doesn't want to exchange
that night as well because he wants to
open up the door for this LightSquared
bishop to really really control this
long dagger night he was kind of blocked
off by that night there on at c3 now
it's time to go ahead and get this pawn
him off so pawn here to d4 trying to
control the center with backup by the
bishop on b2 rook to c8 the pawn can't
say cuz if the pawn were to take all of
a sudden we see Bishop take the bishop
can't take back because then the Queen's
just going to take so because of that
black is kind of forced to instead of
take play his rook over here to c8 first
to kind of protect this and now if he
wants to he could take with his pawn
right here but we see cardiac can decide
he wants to go ahead and take right here
again open up the door for his dark
squared bishop to kind of control after
the pawn takes we do see castle on the
King side now Bishop to f6 just trying
to make sure that white does not
completely dominate this long dagger and
right here and it wasn't doing too much
here on e7 just getting ready for black
to castle on the Kings side but since it
does that wants to get any more
aggressive spots rook over here to d1
it's this kind of shame because the
bishop here on f6 is attacking the pawn
here on h4 this Queen here on d8 is both
protecting this and attacking this and
white only has one defense here so it
kind of looks like black could take with
Bishop to h4 but it gets pretty tricky
here because it's not actually as
protected as he thinks after rook to d5
the Queen can't come down here and take
on d5 that's gonna be a mistake Bishop
to c4 pinning the Queen down to the king
the queen is going to fall now if we
come back here and say well what other
options do we have the Queen is being
under attacked
we could see Queen to e7 this is no
longer under attack and also still
defending the square here on h4 but
white can just take here on h4 and the
Queen can't actually take it the Queen
were to take so Queen takes here on h4
then all of a sudden
rook to d7 and this is pretty deadly
it's attacking both the bishop here on
b7 but it's also threatening the rook to
g7 that is a huge attack this Queen can
also get involved this bishop here on c4
can get involved so it gets pretty
tricky as far as how black really wants
to respond you know one option could be
rook to f7 just trying to kind of block
this off but then we just see Bishop to
b4 pinning down this rook the rook can't
move potentially now the knight comes up
here to DA just adding another defender
on the square here on f7 but then all of
a sudden the bishop would take the
knight takes and then the Queen comes up
here to f5 attacking this square right
here we still have the bishop over here
and this bishop right here is still
under attack very very difficult for
black to deal with if we come back a few
moves on board and say okay what if the
the rook does not move there what if
instead we see another move Knight to e7
okay if he tries to do this instead the
rook and now first take on b7 a now rook
to e8 trying to hold down this material
Bishop to CC for attacking the King King
over here h8 now Queens who c3 a little
bit different move but attacking the
square here on g7
this pawn can't move it gets very
difficult Queen could come here to g5
defending the square here on a g7 but
then pawn to f4 could just kick back to
g6 but then all of a sudden Queen B 5 is
very deadly attacking this square right
here doesn't really matter where black
goes all of a sudden the rook can come
over here to e7 if we do see an exchange
on board the Queen can just take right
here it's just going way down here black
doesn't have much material at all
white on the other side has two bishops
up here it's very difficult for black to
even stop an attack from here so all in
all it's it's pretty deep you have to
get deep in the weeds to actually see
what all is going down but after this
rook here to d1 this pawn here on h4 is
actually surprisingly secure the bishop
can't really take it and it's starting
to put a lot of pressure on at the
center of the board
on d5 we see black play Knight to e7
just putting more defense on the square
on d5 as we talked about and now we see
the bishop take here on f6 and then rook
to f6 capture back that material pawn to
g3 just solidifying this pawn chain
right here on the King side Bishop a6 we
do sting exchange on board and then the
row comes over here to a six and then
Queen to c3 and the Queen has a few
options it could come to d3 to be honest
attacking the rook here on a six c3 is
completely fine it does allow him to
defend the square here on e5 so if he
wants to bring his knight here he does
have that possibility but this would
take our case both sides are fairly
equal in material no one really has a
clear advantage you know black does
control the center of the board here but
he does have kind of these two pawns
kind of hanging pawns and they serve the
board those aren't really a strong pawn
chain so it's not really as big an
advantage is just controlling the center
early on when you have tons of minor
pieces helping control this that's one
thing later on it's a little bit more
difficult when you have kind of your
major pieces you want them to be a
little bit more involved than trying to
hang on to two hanging pawns in this
head of the board rook here to b6
attacking this pawn right here doesn't
have to worry about too much because it
has the Queen rook c1 attacking the
semi-open file
Queen to d6 defending and that's we're
here on a c5 Knight e5 as we talked
about just trying to plug up the center
of the board a rook here to b7 both
sides still fairly equal as far as
material on board and then Knight to d3
pawn c4 pawn takes on c4 rook c4 Queen
e5 which is a nice little move after the
capture right here and the rook takes
pawn to g6 solidifying this pawn chain
which kind of makes sense but then a
rook here to c5 in the exchange the
cardiac and kind of went through just
kind of shows you how deep of an
understanding that some of these players
have going into the endgame we looked at
a position seven eight moves ago that
was fairly even there was no real
advance
for either side and then a small little
exchange on board were both sides they
didn't really gain material but all of a
sudden white now has a clear advantage
not necessarily on the material
standpoint but he he has control of this
board state this rook here on b7 is more
of a defensive square this Knight on e7
can't really move too much can't come to
c6 because the rook and the knight are
attacking it can't come past a d5 or f5
because his own pawns are blocking it
right now neither King is really
involved into the action but this pawns
gonna be able to push a little bit more
than this pawn here on a 7 and he can
really hold on to that a little bit more
with his rook here so white has a much
more aggressive in game and so vision on
for right now
I either has to wait for 78 to kind of
make a mistake or just try to hold on
fort I see King g7 rook to a5 just
attacking the pawn area on a7 and still
holding down the fort here on upon d5
and I can't really move because as soon
as it moves this pawn is going to fall
so this is kind of a stuck spot for the
night here on e7 King to f6 Knight back
here to d3 just trying to get in a
little better position rook c7 rook a6
check King's going to move on Knight to
f4 rook d7 now the King starts activate
King f1 night 2 g8 it's kind of tough
too because the route comes here to d7
to allow the Knights to move but the
Knights kind of moving away from the
board state but there's no other great
squares usually I would say especially
if you're down to material you never
want to get your night away from the
action you want to keep it involved but
you can come to c8 if he wants to
clearly see that c6 would be a bad move
and just be gobbled up a c8 g8 kind of
his only options but neither those even
fill grates if I kind of look at the
board stay
Knight to e6 check King is forced to
move so King f7 a now Knight here to d4
which kind of feels like where he wanted
to be all along Knight here to e7 I mean
he swings it over here to be 5 so the
outpost here on
d4 allows them to come over here attack
this pawn here on a seven-night c8 pawn
a4 so all this and then they kind of
does the one extra move coming up the
board states which is exactly what he's
going for
rook b7 rook c6 attacking the knight
that's gonna come back here to e7 and
then we just kind of come back and forth
a few moves we have a two-fold
repetition Oh Sergei decided okay I can
go ahead and go for the drawl if you
have kind of the same board state three
times in a row threefold repetition is a
drawn game he looked at and said I have
the advantage I'm gonna press this as
much as I can I don't want to draw here
so took a couple moves and then decided
to go ahead and change it up a little
bit so he plays rook here to d6
attacking the pawn here so now we kind
of come back to a state where the knight
can't really move as soon as the knight
moves this pawn is going to fall so it's
kind of stuck right here and then we see
the fatal rook to b6 this is one of
those we're fishing on he just can't
play rook here to b6 he has to kind of
look at it and see that his 7th rank is
just too valuable to give up as soon as
he moves he's got to sit there and hang
on for it's high a rook here to d7 is a
complete dagger as we talked about the
knight can't go anywhere so it's just
kind of pinned down right now
you know this pawn would be under attack
also attacking this pawn I think he
thought okay after a pawn here to a6 I
can just hold onto it with my rook and
that's fine I don't necessarily think
that he looked at Knight to c3 and this
is where vision on decided to go ahead
and resign in the game the Knights gonna
come here to d6 it's gonna go up a
material he has a clear advantage at the
end of the day said again karyakin is is
more than likely going to win the game
now personally I wish the vision I would
have played it out I still think it's a
tough endgame so just so y'all can kind
of see how crazy would get I'll kind of
run through a series of moves just so
you could see some people always ask you
know why would you in this spot
specifically why would you just resign
definitely when I would try to see if my
opponent makes a mistake but rookie
six-night takes on d5 so we kind of know
that's gonna happen
rookie five rook takes on e7 we see an
exchange on board King takes right here
so white is up a pawn but this is not an
easy in game so we'll kind of go through
the scenario where both sides are
rushing their Kings toward the center of
the board
Black's probably gonna get there first
so he's gonna take over here on the
Kings side or the Queen side why it's
gonna focus on the Kings side so King e2
King d6 King d3 King c5 e 4 needs to
start attacking on the Kings side since
he's not gonna win the race over here we
see King before pawn g4 pawn takes check
King recaptures King captures here on a4
so we do have a race here pawn f4 king
b5 now King d5 making sure there's no
shenanigans going on King a5 starting to
push up the board a for pawn to f6
didn't really matter if you know the
pawn takes just waste a move here the
pawn recaptures we're gonna essentially
see the same thing here but pardon a3
pawn f7 pawn a 2 Queens have fate so
white does get their one move ahead and
so white does win but for a lot of fans
out there that kind of wish fishing on
and go gone through the motions there's
there's so many different ways that
white could have made a mistake here and
he could've at least kind of draw if not
a win by some miracle but all-in-all
vision on kind of looked at I think he
was just upset with the fact that he
gave up that seventh rank and he
resigned so congratulations to Sergey
Kathy Hawken he's in first place Levon
Aronian did have a drawl so Roni is in
second place and then busy and on kind
of drops to that third spot does have a
win but he also now has a loss as well
so four rounds in the books this is a
long tournament so many many rounds to
come but hopefully you guys enjoyed this
one and I'll see you guys tomorrow for
round five